add to our top story car thefts continue
to plague the valley thank you for
joining us at four I'm Brian Loftus and
I'm Ozzie Moore and for Kirsten Joyce
recently a viewer reaching out to us
about a string of thefts
her complex in North Las Vegas near
Commerce and Tropical Parkway 8 news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough spoke to
residents at Azure apartment homes on
what they want to happen
a week ago a lady's car was broken into
and stolen that lady 72 year old Sharon
has lived at the complex for years two
weeks ago her Hyundai was stolen from a
handicapped spot when I came out there
was no car in that parking spot I walked
all around I went in the house got my
son-in-law he walked all around with me
we couldn't find it but I've seen a lot
of glass right there her neighbor Alyssa
who doesn't want to be shown on camera
reached out directly to 8 news now she's
frustrated over the constant car thefts
and break-ins and she wants more help
for management our work vehicle we took
home and my husband's tools were stolen
over three thousand dollars worth of
tools and all that was told to us was
sorry there's nothing we can do it was
here underneath this awning that several
cars were stolen overnight and according
to North Las Vegas PD 13 police reports
were filed including two for vehicle
thefts and when they told me they didn't
have security cameras I was kind of
shocked when I spoke to Azure Apartment
Homes management they acknowledged the
car thefts have been happening but had
no further comment Alyssa and Sharon
both say in order for them to continue
living there their safety has to be
considered and on-site security and
cameras on premises is a must I hope
they get security
that's what we need this complex is
pretty big we went there because the
property was great the rent price was
great but now we understand why there
was a lot of vacancy you know all of
these steps
a reminder don't leave anything of value
in your car if you do leave personal
items in there put it in a covered trunk
while it's hot make sure to close your
windows and double check doors are
locked police also recommend an
anti-theft device such as a steering
wheel lock as well